我真的是非常讨厌
下巴还比以额头
这边经常会长的种命连满满的小颗粒
特别是下巴这边
你摸上去感觉像杀紙一样
只有想完全折不住他们
就像我用再贵的粉底看起来
装干还是很差
后来我发现针对这种颗粒脸
就必须要死克平镇度
我研究出的改善流程
做一两次之后
就会发现皮膚整体的会吸膩光滑很多
就算之后
你再用那种几十块钱很便宜的粉底
打开的底装
装央是很吸膩的
那如果你是那种很容易命
很怕用酸翻车的话
就可以试试我等下分享
这个无酸模皮流程
因为我们脸上会长种小颗粒
它其实就是那种老废脚制
对积度出毛控脚制的
所以我们要一步一步的把这些
赞东西给它处理掉
我们先用这个热盆来噴脸十分钟
如果你没有热盆的话
你就洗一个热水脏
然后再来做这个流程
让我们后续清楚
赞东西的步驻更好的战开
保持干手干脸
然后用一个西装勇
重点的去揉错
这种我们非常容易长颗粒的地方
以游融油
由于两分钟样子就会感觉
练上的有一些小颗粒
被我们揉下来了
下完整把这个舌头底住
把它这个下面撑开去揉它
我揉个差不多的
现在呢
我去加一点水
去给它煮化下把它洗干净
好 我喜欢脸回来了
这一步效我们毛控口
有一些对应机的当中
是就可以被我们揉掉不上
接下来我们来处理一下
藏的比较深的那种老废脚制
就是这些东西才是让我们
长着小颗粒的根源
不会用比较温和的调历型精华水来做师傅
帮我软化脚制打开皮膚通道
让那种老废脚制
可以更加深入的被处理脚
但是要注意并不要选
很酸或是酒精那种
容易吃起皮膚的
会容易加重到我们的明明
最好是选那种可以帮我改善
粗粒用的够帮我补水
修互的功能型精华水
这一步的话
我就会用这个
外塞的调皮水来做师傅
用它之前呢
它就是要鲜腰鱼食杏飘
让这个是有充分的混合
把它倒在这个社会面上
然后重点复降我们俄头
比一下把这种比较容易长小颗粒的地方
我觉得它完全是不能用酸心人的平滑神器
所以它里面是没有酸的
但是它把酸的是都盖明白了
平滑安嫩夫的效果就是肉眼可见
它靠的就是里面的
先人长化已经脆无事靠酸去荣油
也不会去暴力地波脱我们的老废脚制
而是加速我们皮膚自己的这种更新的功能
慢慢的让我们连上这种老废脚制
主动的下感
本来是还扶拍到很多修互乘门的
就可以一边帮我们产除
老废脚制
一边帮我们做好修互
但皮膚有点明的时候
用它一完全不用担心会翻车
它是这种水油双像的制抵
这个配比就是超级天后我们本身的平滑
所以我用它就感觉上脸修的一下
就可以被皮膚吸收进去了
我们看到我们现在等五分钟
像我平时早两护服第一步的话
也喜欢用它来给我摩一下皮
用它大概一周的样子
就感觉我整个脸
像开的那种云夫一样
非常的干净光滑
像有的时候你化妆前
如果感觉皮膚就是有那种科律感很粗糙的话
也可以拿它是封一下
不然它之后在上的装
你随便拿一个粉底
就可以打出现在大最喜欢的那种
Clean Make Up心头底装
好了五分钟到现在我们把它给接下来吧
接下来这一刻被经济到的
要感觉皮膚亮亮的
一点都不有膩
变单身那种摸起来软软的嫩嫩的性依赶
这个时候我们这个师傅没有标认掉了
你就在我们这种非常容易长小科技的地方
你用这个化妆免轻轻的打圈
打圈完之后你再摸着我的地方
秘密麻烦的科律感直接就担掉一大半
那这个的话我们又不需要洗掉了
它牠牠牠牠牠牠牠非常快的
我们再抽一个可以修护的乌叶来给它封层
像我们这种皮膚就是因为平常不健康
楼指索并望圣
脸上水游不平衡才长这些小科律一个个搭搭的
所以我们日常的话也是要维护好我们这个平常
我用的是这个通款的调皮融
它可以把我脸上这种
平款的状态给我汉在脸上
让我们的皮膚状态越来越稳定
致致也是那种非常非常舒服的
一抹就爆水的这种致紧
推开这种就是鳥吸收
我们油皮用着针的一点都不油膩
非常非常清爽
皮膚的平镇度比较高
状态好的话整个人的气质看起来也会好很多
那长期被这种妈妈来来骗着姐妹真的可以试试这个流程
效果真的很好